let's uh jump to the big breaking news
everybody
from the daily mail white cop who shot
jacob blake seven times in front of his
kids will not face charges
kenosha brings in national guard and
braces for
unrest as d.a refuses to prosecute
officer
who left black man paralyzed on tuesday
the kenosha county district attorney
michael gravely said his office will not
file charges against the white police
officer rustin
chesky chesky was the officer who shot
jacob blake
this is really interesting daily med
just has to put black man jacob blake
seven times
leaving him paralyzed on august 23rd
chesky has responded to a uh had
responded to a call about a domestic
incident
and opened fire as blake was getting
into his suv whereas three young
children watched in kenosha wisconsin
i also want to point out that did they
say he was reaching for a knife where he
had a knife
jacob blake did everyone's nodding yes
yeah
he said it is incontrovertible here we
go it is incontrovertible that blake had
a knife
saying officers reported seeing a razor
blade type knife
ahead of the announcement wisconsin
mobilized the national guard
kenosha declared a state of emergency
blake's lawyers condemned the decision
saying
this sends the wrong message to police
officers throughout the country
it says it is okay for police to abuse
their power
and recklessly shoot their weapons now
while this is happening we also have
news coming out of npr that kyle
rittenhouse
is pleading not guilty to all charges
for those that aren't familiar
kyle rittenhouse is the young man who
showed up to the riots that that ignited
because of the jacob blake incident
and long story short is clear-cut
self-defense as far as i'm concerned the
i mean you even have some leftists who
brought it up and got really roasted for
destiny in particular
this is a kid kyle rittenhouse um he was
working in wisconsin
someone in wisconsin had given him
weapon probably a bad idea kid probably
shouldn't have been there
but we had several witnesses on the show
who told us what happened these are
journalists who were there on the ground
like richie mcginnis
who actually rendered aid to one of the
guys who got shot and died
and i mean they multiple witnesses told
us the rioters were pushing a flaming
dumpster to a gas station and kyle
rittenhouse
took a fire extinguisher and i'm sorry
kyle renas is seen running with a fire
extinguisher
but there's videos of him and other
people putting fires out this
triggered the riders they got really mad
they chased after him attacked him
and then someone else fired a gun into
the air
in the direct or some say it's in the
air others say it was in the direction
of rittenhouse and the guy chasing him
uh this guy i think his name was
rosenbaum one of the guys who died and
then rittenhouse
hearing the gunshot turned around and
that's when the dude swung at him and he
fired
he runs as far as i'm concerned it looks
like self-defense
the crazy thing is the left is saying
outright no way he's he's you know it's
a terrorist and a mass shooter and all
this crazy stuff but
it's really worrying to me when you have
situations like this low information
individuals who don't watch the videos
or just don't
care take that into consideration now as
they're saying this cop is not being
charged
i'll open up to the panel gentlemen uh
is the right a coming
duh i mean is the sky blue
i mean it's i mean right now we're
getting the reports of the mayor asking
everyone to be peaceful
we're getting reports of the blake
family and supporters already marching
through the city
who knows how it's going to turn out but
as you were mentioning with the kyle
situation kyle's legal team actually
released
their version of events their video
their photos of what
happened to them and the depictions were
almost completely opposite of what the
mainstream media was depicting and
telling us was happening
so again based on you know both of those
two stories
look at both of them make up your own
decision but also in this story
like you were reading it you see race
being weaponized by the mainstream media
and you always see white man
black man but you know this is only
particularly in this
instance but when it comes to other
instances when they can't weaponize it
they can't use it to divide and conquer
people they can't use it to put fuel on
the fire they don't mention it
i think i think our media has a
vestigial or some kind of sickness yeah
ill intentional no no no
look like there was a reason why you
would write about a white man attacking
a black man
because we had serious racism in
american history we had like the civil
rights era
but were were well past that era i'm not
going to say everything's perfect
but certainly we've done we've made
great strides and now we have this
problem where the media
still wants to highlight the race of the
of
the people even though that's not what
caused any of this
as a police officer getting a report of
a woman who had just been assaulted
in her bed by this man who then reached
for a knife which
even the even the court was saying
incontrovertible the dude had a weapon
they recovered the weapon he said he had
a weapon and the cop said drop it
several times and the dude
jacob blake didn't listen he was
actually fighting the cops
they got to make it about race though
could you imagine what would happen if
our laws were just like it doesn't
matter if you're innocent or guilty it
matters what your race is
because that's part of what we're
looking at too no i don't wanna i don't
wanna derail too much but i don't know
if you guys saw
the cdc was advising to give the vaccine
based on race
now i'm supposed to be convinced that
medicare for all is the appropriate way
to go
the government should be in control of
healthcare when you're telling me
they're gonna give on race that's creepy
stuff man
it's creepy but now you've got people i
don't i don't know let me ask you guys
i think it's obvious to a lot of people
it seems probably like a redundant
question but the left
rioting and protesting in a situation
like this ignorance
exploitation both both absolutely
absolutely both and and uh our
you know democratic presidential
candidates uh they totally took
advantage of it they kept saying oh well
you know oh we're so proud of jacob
blake like
really proud proud of him that's that's
great
this is a creepy not a criminal i know
this is a family-friendly show
but the things he was doing to that
woman i can't say no when
he was pinning her down and i can't
repeat what she what
i mean well assault is assault yes yeah
well i'm but
we got to keep it family-friendly right
going into details on that stuff
we'll get demonetized we'll get deranked
it was serious stuff
where was the metoo movement this dude
was was was wanted
for abusing a woman pinning her down in
her bed
and the cops were trying to stop him
and he fought with them could you
imagine any other scenario what would
happen if those cops died
would there be riots for them no no no
no
not in that situation so what do you
what do you do
actually what's what's so what are we
supposed to do as a
as a society when you have something
like the metoo movement demanding that
these men be held accountable
right but when the cops actually come to
hold him accountable they blame the cops
i mean believe all women i mean like who
who called 9-1-1 right it was a it was
you know the the mother who is an
african-american woman
so you'd think that you know just on the
intersectionality
pyramid that you know she's black and
she's a woman and hey you know you have
to believe her even more
yeah right but instead but instead like
oh no
this you know this man was was uh you
know shot with a gun and
you know and it's it's yeah and and
everybody just took advantage of it like
how
how you know kamala was meeting with his
family and meeting with him
on bedside it's like for what like what
did he do
this guy's not a hero information voters
man and i'm very happy you brought up
camel uh kamala or kamala i don't know
how to
say her name sorry i'm already arrested
throw me the bullock please i made a big
misnomer here yeah but it's funny you
bring
her up because specifically also talking
about believe all women she's the one
that went after joe biden very
hard against the allegations against him
and other women
and now she's also blinded to it the
people who are adding fuel to the fire
are
filled with so much hypocrisy the only
constant
is joe biden who previously was for
segregation
also kind of pushing for segregation
issues
right now in our modern day and age he
never changed he never changed so that's
the only consistency that we have here
with the establishment and of course the
mainstream media follows and
and regurgitates everything they say has
it always been this bad
problem no no i think probably way worse
before so there well
i think it's it's it's the rhetoric has
been there
it's just that social media and you know
a hundred thousand cable channels
and youtube channels just amplify it so
it just seems louder it seems
like it's a bigger thing but like um
there was a there was a john wayne
interview from years past and he was
basically saying that
that the left are the they're the
loudest voices and if you don't listen
to them if you don't
agree with their ideology that you're
wrong and that you're like a bad person
and that they just keep driving at home
that that you need
if you don't believe in this you're
wrong and you're bad
you have to believe in this which is the
the right way and the only way
and that was back in the 70s
that so this has always been that way
yeah there was there was a story from
npr where they said
40 of like people believe
ridiculous conspiracy theories and i
know something really interesting
npr separates what they called incorrect
statements from correct statements
and then you see that among the
incorrect statements more people believe
them
versus the correct statements but there
is one big differentia uh one one that
differentiates the two
was timeliness people believe the
conspiracies
if it's new if it's in the recent
history and they believe overwhelmingly
the mainstream narrative
if it was long since passed right so one
of the questions was like was was
barack obama born in america most people
like 75 percent said yes and then like
20 said not sure smaller percentage said
no
but that's because that was back 2008
well before social media
what i and then and the advent of big vc
funded blogs
take a look at wikipedia right now and i
think this is the perfect example
you go to any conservatives uh wikipedia
and it is an aggregation of
negative opinions from left-wing
activists that's not a biography of
somebody like if i really wanted to know
say who
like jack posobik was i don't need to
hear that you think he's far right
alt-right
you know ultra-right you know
nationalist or all of these other
opinions you have about them
that they're like you get a whole
paragraph like it's been disputed as to
what he personally believes
you get the guy on record saying what he
believes but they'll put into wikipedia
all of their opinions about him they're
as negative as possible
because what's happened now is we've got
millions of different websites
and they all just repeat everything that
gets the clicks
so kamala harris doesn't care if jacob
blake
was sexually abusing this woman right no
one's gonna find out because they're not
gonna read the news
well they either slander or also
disappear you just like they did with
chris martinson just like they did with
me personally but also another thing
that i wanted to bring up here
when segregationists were making the
arguments that people should stay
uh you know stay apart because of their
race one of the things they used to do
is they used to highlight certain events
and also do what the mainstream media is
doing now
and highlight the race of a specific uh
attacker the race of a specific victim
and use that as propaganda in order to
galvanize people to be
for segregation and then when we see
this weaponized in so many instances
it's so weird seeing that being the
major highlight
rather than the actual discussion of
what actually happened
who was actually right what is the
evidence can we make up our mind here
when we first are able to actually see
what happened rather than jump into
conclusions and being kind of
radicalized as the internet as social
media as the algorithms as the timelines
as the as everything that the big tech
monopolies shove down your throat
are showing you as it is so here's a
really good example of like how screwed
up everything is and why you end up with
these
imbalanced riot type situations was the
leaked phone call with trump
you listened to it yeah the four minutes
that come out
trump's like i need to find eleven
thousand seven hundred and eighty votes
and then all the left is screaming it's
worse than watergate
and they're throwing up on themselves
and convulsing and then i'm like well
i'd sure love to hear the full audio
of the phone call and then it turns out
there's a little bit of bad stuff trump
said but for the most part it's kind of
mad there's a little bit of bad stuff
that
raffenberger said and it's kind of meh
but if you actually approach that story
from a legitimate journalistic point of
view you'd say okay well it's not that
big of a deal that trump said that he
was talking about the various areas
where they have found or they believe
they have fraudulent votes and he was
saying
we don't need to do a hard investigation
of every single accusation we just need
eleven thousand seven eighty
but you also had statements from brad
referenceburger like he didn't know
that georgia even had a consent decree
that's kind of a big deal
so if you approached that and you leaked
the audio of say brad raffensberger
saying
we can confirm debt voters which he said
and we have
uh no consent decree you could have
leaked that portion and been like whoa
whoa crazy but the washington post which
especially mainstream media
ignored the things that referenceburger
was saying that were questionable
and only presented the things that they
could take to make trump look bad
and then and then everybody reported on
those four minutes
and it was it was um it was at least a
couple hours until they released
the full the full hour recording but at
that point
nobody's going to be listening to that
strategic yeah and
and and just the fact that when you go
and look for that news
that cbs and abc they're all focusing on
those four minutes on that one line they
need to do so
what's the narrative now with jayco
blake because i don't want to derail too
much but
in what reality is there a leftist
saying
it was good that jacob like like that
these
these cops it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter he was black that's it
it all has to do with race that's it
that's the lens that they're that they
that it's not that they're forced to do
it it's what they want to do
they want to look down that lens and say
it's all about race as
i mean yeah but i mean when you
when you look at all you know
when you even even with george floyd
uh was it was it what was inside his
body
that that killed him no
right what was it was it all these
things that it uh
exacerbated that and then yeah
the full video released later on showing
it was much more nuanced than
i would want to believe but but even
even after
th that was leaked and and these cops
are overcharged i don't think they're
going to see they in prison
i agree uh but even even after that full
audio was leaked
it was ignored it was completely ignored
they did not
talk about the trump thing no no the
george floyd's body cam footage gets
released
he's like put me on the ground he's
gonna die today i'm gonna die today when
he's in the back of the car and he's
saying i can't breathe
for 20 minutes while he's in the back of
the car and then he says take me out put
me on the ground right several times and
this is they did
and but the thing is and you're right
it's v it's
much it was much more nuanced than that
but nobody cares
because it no no no it goes against the
narrative that that it was
here's it's this it's this simple the
people that care
are a problem for the establishment
machine
that just wants blind zealots to say
tell me what to do please
it's like it reminds me that scene from
avengers when loki is like he tells
everyone to bow and says is this not
better
your natural state there's that one guy
who stood up and said
i won't bow to you that's like your av
like the average people in the know who
are questioning the media
but the democrats seek out those who
would just drop to their knees and say
just tell me what to do
i don't want to be involved i'll do
whatever you say it's easier that way
so when you take a regular person that's
why we have the idea of the red pilling
in the in the blue pill
people because you got regular people
who i think the hunter biden story is
probably the best example of why
nobody believes the media anymore
because they npr said we won't waste our
time on non-stories
so here you've got some imagine you've
got some 40 year old dude and he's like
he's in his in his house and his you
know his wife is
making breakfast for the kids and then
he's like i can go to work and then he
turns you know
he's watching cnn and they're like the
hunter biden thing's fake news and he
goes yeah i thought so
and now a month later they're like
hunter biden it's all true and he's
going
what are you are you kidding me a month
ago you said it was fake now you're
saying it's just
probably like russian disinformation
they they hear it's fake it's gone and
then a month later comes out it was true
and they're like
what was true what is that that i don't
even remember what they're talking about
yeah about
hunter or which is that not everybody
watches cousin's son or something
they don't they don't watch all the news
all the time but i have to imagine
there's a lot of people
who wake up when they see this and they
say i care about what's going on
i care about why my checks are are you
know smaller
i care about why my you know property
value is is like going through the roof
is inflating in certain areas
and why certain goods are really
expensive at the store now and they turn
to the news and look for answers and you
don't get it anymore no not on the news
not all that crap it's like right that
same corporate is that
they got they they talk like this they
have that same and coming up and it's
like
date and then it shows the graph it's
like there's a comfort even tucker
carlson yeah even tucker carlson has
that like
he's not the same as the way you know
news people talk
but he has his tv style presentation
which is i always just find it weird
normal um who is it
rachel maddow sounds like chris
hayes they sound alike when they talk
and they look the same like the same
style
people don't realize they're reading a
script what matters is who's writing the
script and many times we see many big
organizations just regurgitate press
releases they do it for smaller
companies they do it for special
interests so what makes you think
they're not doing it for bigger
interests for bigger powers out there
that benefit off of people fighting each
other
rather than of course looking at the
real problems the real injustice is the
real things that actually go out there
and touch them
in the average day and life of a human
being those issues are usually just
scrapped to the side meanwhile hey look
it's black man white man whoa thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you